I think it's funny in that there's
definitely a huge difference between how
you dis explain design in from a market
perspective and how you would explain
design as the curator at MoMA in my
world design really is about beauty it's
about how does this work fit in with my
collection how does this look next to
everything else in my collection it
really has nothing to do with the old
form versus function debate ornament can
still be crime in that in the
contemporary design movement but the
work itself is frequently an ornament
it's not about a work having ornament
applied to it it's about the work itself
mimicking sculpture mimicking
contemporary art and that is the the
fundamental basis of contemporary design
in the market world on the other side of
the coin if I was to become a full-on
curator at an institution I would be far
more concerned with good design that
question what is good design and an
informant function and thus one of my
heroes one of my personal heroes over
the last 20 years in terms of I who is
the most innovative smartest designer of
our times to which I would say jasper
morrison you know morrison is not much
of a presence in the market because
everything he does is so minimalist and
so oriented towards function making this
piece work with his few steps of